BAM welcome to the Friday games review
oh yeah rolling it again alright again
to the Friday review alright I'm Dan
Galpin and with me is Andy Lewis we're
kicking it old-school today we decided
we've been doing a lot to bring the
quality of the show up and you know lots
of new shots you effects low quality
today that's where at man yeah today we
just dragged out the bar table we got
the beers and honestly we're just gonna
talk games yeah and if you guys want to
stick around that's cool let's talk it
that's right and we've what we actually
have looked at the moderator page and
guys stop nominating stuff we've already
looked at man come on also like stuff
that's garbage
oh yeah but no you know there's some
good stuff here but you know really like
we've already reviewed it we're not
gonna review it again unless you've done
like something totally kick-ass awesome
with yeah but seriously you know a we're
we're tired yeah yeah lots of stuff
going down here at work but all good
good stuff good stuff for you I guess
we're gonna get you promoted man that's
alright so anyway we've got a lot of
stuff to talk about but I think we're
gonna we're gonna do a little bit of
game review or think we're just gonna
talk a little bit about games we've
actually been doing we every every now
and then we kind of do a sweep of a
bunch of games are popular yeah to see
you know how well they're working on
different devices and if there's any
issues with them developers do voices
like interesting things yeah that's what
we learned so yeah we've we've learned
some really interesting things and I
think it would be fun to talk about them
and it's the same time we'd like to you
know look at a few games and maybe mock
some it's possible yeah well you know we
have we have we have our good friends
from com2us nominated a game and their
games are always fun because they don't
they aren't intended to appeal to
a cultural norm do you remember when we
had to spend that one game back and say
we're not gonna feature it unless you
take out the giant red phallus I guess
it was supposed to be a rocket it was it
was but it the problem is and you make a
rocket with two giant round orbs on the
side of it it really does have the wrong
impression when the nose cone is purple
yes yeah absolutely
it was anyway today we're drinking
Lagunitas IPA mm-hmm Cheers
we need if they my friend the fam stir
because I've totally run through my beer
budget and I'm now gonna start spending
it on something else like where's oh you
know come on it's the beer budget that's
true that's true no actually you know
what I'm spending it on now is audio
stuff lights in lights yep because we
need key lights we need key lights
coming right back here shining down on
your shoulders that's right it's gonna
make your hair look luxurious so and I'm
wearing a hat again because there was
some public outcry about the fact that I
had no hat last week so once again but
what's what it what is what is fun is
that I'm actually performing at an opera
right now and in my spare time I thought
you said they were gonna make you cut
your hair plug yeah we were going to but
never build well no I didn't actually
cast members rebelled actually they
first tried to put me in a wig and they
put me in a wig that was honestly like
the $20.00 wig special and I looked like
I was a game show host
and you know when you're in an opera
where you're supposed to be in like 1890
or something like that and you look like
you know wink Martindale it just it just
doesn't work Dale I miss that guy do too
but that but they did make me actually
dye my beards this is this is not the
normal color so it shows better on video
I think I'm gonna go go Azure Oh for
Halloween this year because I didn't do
you think I'm rocking to Zorro look
probably like fats or I was we're going
for Oh and just because we're probably
gonna die halfway through when the
YouTube stream cuts out might as well
say right now that next week will be a
perfect time to talk about Halloween
apps absolutely and Halloween games so
you know we're we're gonna we're gonna
actually have a two weeks of Halloween
games so you know you didn't actually
say some of the moderator pages yet but
please nominate some Halloween games
otherwise I'm gonna nominate them so
yeah I don't think it's really a risk I
think that there's plenty of in fact
there's so many games out there
seriously exactly right now here we are
it's farmville with zombies yep zombie
Ville there actually is actually so I'm
really excited to see if there's gonna
be an Android version my one of my old
co-workers from project offset did a
mobile game called brains it's a it's a
zombie realtime strategy game oh yeah
it's right up your alley
you play the zombie horde oh that's
awesome
that's very sweet it's interesting okay
so so it's a no I'm looking forward to
that that that sounds cool and so right
now I will say the closest we have to
Halloween you we do have we do have
which Wars on tap for today but it's not
really a Halloween with no no they're
sort of your sexy anime which yeah
that's why I would describe it so and
it's weird because you pointed out there
they do have handcuffs as one of the
things they let's let's look yeah as
judge for those so let's take a look at
now you'll notice that we've completely
a skewed lower thirds today we don't
have any titles or anything though
you'll have to figure out what you
looking at on time so it's a mystery
disconnected to the server
oops oops wait hold on basically what we
gave back is if there's like a lot of
hating in the YouTube comments yeah well
first we'll discount 90% of it because
that's what you do with YouTube comments
if you want to remain sane no offense
wait did we start out saying that's the
real question
no talking about any of our live viewers
because they all rock yes point being
that we are kind of like just winging
this show today but we'd love to hear
yeah as sort of a you know counterpoint
to what we've been doing before which is
kind of like slick and overproduced I
guess you know what do you think yeah
exactly let us let us know do you want
us to continue over producing we can do
that we can make more 3d titles we can
use more effects we can use more
green-screen
we get a big have us on freaking Mars
man that's for the next for the next
show right up to you
got a green screen bonus burning a hole
in my pocket and a your subscription to
Dobie cs6 yeah exactly man after we're
gonna use After Effects on your butt so
guys I just put up a lower thirds for
you guys doesn't that despite awesome
thank you we have lower thirds now so
yes the title is which wars and and let
me another fact you restart no wait a
second damn right there's the witches
okay so that's look and yeah this damn
plate it's really interesting to me it
seems like there's here that yeah that
you need to match yes how many do you
need to match three three really okay
yeah that's interesting and there's like
a grid of them and they're all different
sorts Bob
yes but I'm playing against another
which you see okay so she's like she's
like kicking my butt now cuz knocking oh
you're totally racing what you're saying
is I'm talking so you're not getting any
work done exactly
hey wait I'm sending a message here I'm
just saying no this thing okay so anyway
yeah play man when restarting hey is it
always the same witches I you know
although I don't know okay I'm then the
question is yeah why do they have hands
handcuffs well yeah that I didn't
understand the handcuffs part is there
is there so let us know on the live
stream is there some sort of witch thing
with handcuffs that we should be aware
of that you know that we I mean I
understand like you know the the Penta
the the star pentagram and stuff like
that you know that's that kind of stuff
I in you know the the Star of David is
kind of a kind of a sort of witchy thing
to some people but yeah come on tell me
what this is I don't I don't get the
symbolism here maybe I'm trying to read
too much yeah that is weird this a Star
of David like wouldn't be like a
pentagram it should be a pentagram is
just like just all completely messed up
it's possible I I just I just don't know
I'm honestly I haven't had enough to
drink yet to get this game so yeah you
are a little you want to jump in and we
you guys in the comments okay so this is
for one of our longtime viewers hundred
goat he says the last minute title card
actually looks better than the formerly
overproduced
title card oh oh that's like that's
awesome that it's not we are we are so
okay okay good to know good to know I
blame though he's got it he's got a good
point
I blinky note for that actually well
I'll tell you what happened is we yeah
we threw together that that that thing
in keynote and it looked good at the
time and then one of the reasons we
don't have it now is because we got
really sick of it and didn't like it at
all so you're with us actually yeah
we're totally with you yeah well we're
gonna when we actually have time next
week maybe we'll do another one that's
cooler but you know just so you know
that's not a thrown together
title card that is an original Roman of
New York title card oh you hate vast
sums
yeah his salary all right so what what
does this have that other match three
games don't have it of course you always
get asked it is soda sit is the battle
element we're all just trying the most
lost a totally new so it's got witches
and handcuffs and a and battles and
spells and it's actually pretty cool
like honestly it's fun where there's
spells
yeah we get spells by matching up
certain skills you see and then you can
cast spells on explosions so yeah so it
is actually I mean honestly it's fun you
know if you like these kind of games
there's there's ones that really have a
lot more depth in terms of like
progression like you know one of my
favorite ones was called Atlantis I
actually played all the way through from
player X we've talked about it a few
times on here because I like the fact
that you actually got to different
cities and got to different challenges
and but this is fun for what it is it's
sort of it sort of reminds me actually
of the the classic puzzle fighter in the
sense that you're sort of you know
you're you know in kind of battling
against something yeah thinking you know
it's by taking it to match three instead
of instead of two you know a puzzle
bobble kind of thing yeah yeah so you
know I say cool nice nice nice mashup of
game genres I always appreciate mashups
as far as the graphics we have really
kind of blue
as backgrounds with high-res icons if
you actually look you look at the
Thunder of you can see this in the live
stream but you actually can see like the
vs. is really kind of blurry and the
backgrounds are really blurry but then
the icons look beautiful I think you
like ask yourself if that just did that
if they then just decided okay this
background is too big nobody'll notice
if we just blur it out a little bit yeah
you know III I'm sure they were trying
to make the apk size small which I
appreciate it I would say one thing that
was great about today all these games
installed in like four minutes like like
like honestly they were well we're all
tiny games I'm like Bard's Tale
I like Bart said yeah last week and I
was like installing Bart yeah which by
the way is awesome thank you in exile
for for doing that that's that's like it
made my whole week the fact that we had
bars tail on on Android finally but but
yeah it's freaking enormous and mostly
because of the song about beer beer beer
tiddly beer beer oh I got stunned as
Tommy Tallarico you don't cut out his
song no you don't you happily don't and
it's Kerry Ellis as the as the narrator
a not as a narrator as the as the bard
so you know you gotta appreciate your
you know the funny thing is I the last
time I played Bard's Tale uh-huh was
actual Bard's Tale like yeah they came
here and I'm missing one of the two
versions I really was it actually comes
with that yes yeah and it's not nearly
as good as I remember when you're way
back back then a 240 by 240 graphic you
know like 16 colors was awfully gloomy
away yeah it's like how did they get so
many colors on the screen right well
because I had a VGA monitor you've been
put into 256 color mode as long as
you're willing to go down to QVGA so one
thing is intrigued about this game this
game actually uses come to us is look
back in game totally stuffed idler this
thing I know I know I know but you
didn't even say anything you didn't say
you didn't say like oh shut up Ian let's
talk about this you just like acted like
I wasn't even talking so no I mean I
totally know I totally missed that
actually not one of my favorite things I
I had an original like you know CGA
adapter for my PC and most people didn't
realize if you actually hooked it up to
a composite monitor and you had the
right games it could actually display 16
colors at one so that's how the original
King's Quest worked and I used the same
right right because it yeah it does it
was like a with a scanline or was it
block it was block yeah block pellet
right yeah so and basically you would
you would you you have two lines you put
them right next to each other
horizontally and then you end up getting
the color on composite because of the
you know kind of effect raster effect
you got from that regular to what you
got an Apple to you so remember the
Commodore 64 did that but they didn't
actually have enough memory so every
pixel ended up being twice as wide yes
all right back to which words days which
worse so yeah I'm to overall you know
pretty good I mean my main my main thing
is it like it pushes the the contrast
social network into like new levels of
annoyance if you don't want to actually
use it but the game the game plays why
no I mean what is it doing well okay so
the first let's see if I can actually
replicate it I might have to clear I
mean well I just didn't I didn't see it
come up or anything okay
it all starts all really long time to
load I don't know why it's like refining
swords and like like dude what are you
copying something to that from the apk
file I mean it's this game is tiny like
I'm not sure what it's doing delivering
steelbooks
like is it copied kaki the network I
just want to play I want to go to my
which action on and livering handcuffs
ordered from the shopping mall obviously
there's something up in yeah I this game
I know yeah I don't know how to
interpret this but oh so then and then
when it comes up actually I end up
getting you end up getting the you know
some sort of news it looks like it's
it's actually being nice to me the
second time it's not actually forcing me
into lots and lots of stuff which is so
give you some some ads up front it just
adds like like like a kind of a general
guy sign I don't know anyway I'm sure
these guys know what they're doing they
make you know oodles and oodles of sales
and especially in Korea occur I didn't I
like Oh cursor and restrictions well
yeah I would say I don't quite know what
they're doing they're closed well it's
just they don't all right my personal
theory is that their most of their
translation department is like nephews
well I'm just saying that you know you
like like this is a word wrapping thing
though here actually let me explain it
to you okay okay now
alright you and I yeah rap words one on
syllables that's cuz we rap right yeah
you know what this is this is how you do
word rapping going them style alright
alright so anyways we'll quit let's go
let's go to our next game I figure I
have to look we have to look at happy
sheet we have to look at happy sheep but
only because we want to know if anyone
on the live stream can explain this game
to us the sheep are happy well they're
very happy and it's like I I mean I
think I definitely got past the first
level and I'm pretty sure I knew how I
got past the first level I just alright
play button really close to
advertisement clever alright so so your
goal is to get the sheep into the bar
and I think and you do that partially by
flicking them I think but mostly by
using these oh you know what flicking is
not actually a part of it oh it is not a
mechanic it's because if you try it Wow
because if you if you really pay
attention
it's just tapping them oh I don't think
it's actually recording well so
basically you put the barn at the bottom
of the screen and just let everything
fall yeah I guess so
so the sheep are happy mostly you know
and that's good they have they have one
frame of animation on them which is you
know it which makes them look happier
there's a dog I'm not sure what the dog
does except I guess it blocks you from
getting sheep in if it happens to be in
the right place that doesn't make sense
it seems like the dogs should be helping
you get the Sheep it totally totally but
you know dogs doc you know that you do
have sheep dogs that are working in it
that go with sheep ooh
we just lost HDMI cuz you know micro
HDMI socks there we are alright but but
anyway so that's that's the game you can
see on a tablet we're seeing some minor
sprite alignment errors you can see the
classic around the chickens you can see
their little lines around the chickens
and a little line around the dog and
this is pretty common if you're using a
sprite sheet and you're trying to break
things up and run
of higher resolution alright stop
playing that game seriously oh yeah what
why because you keep tilting it around
it keeps popping out the connector oh
well I'm holding the connector in now
well you're not holding it right I'm not
holding it right in the tables you know
what you're cut off come on come on come
on oh but I have a couple of great
comments from our yeah let's hear some
viewer comments so the first comment is
that flicking your sheep causes
blindness just saying good idea good
point talking about yeah exactly
and the second comment is that someone
wants to see us abused a green screen in
horrible ways yeah alright believe me we
love we're saving it for the outtakes
video but I will say this about time you
see the the sprite outlines that you saw
did not occur without the HDMI connector
plugged in so this is something that
we're actually starting to learn is it's
really really important to go in and
test your game at really bizarre
resolutions yeah
because sooner or later no matter what
resolution you think is never gonna
happen in the real world it's gonna hit
the streets of Shenzhen at half the
price of everything else and Samsung is
gonna snap up a boatload of them yeah I
mean people I'm always amazed with what
we're getting in terms of screens I mean
even in terms of last year when you know
I was kind of amazed that we actually
had a device wish that was shipping out
on a phone form factor with 720p that
was last year oh yeah god only knows
yeah exactly what's gonna happen this
year so um but it's not just that yeah
it's it's that you think you think Oh
720p that's that's pretty crazy yeah but
what's really crazy is 735 P well yeah
which is actually that we were because
we were actually are actually at on this
device we're actually running at true
720p when you're in HDMI but you're not
an HDMI were in this kind of weird funky
thing where we're actually right you
know 35 or 40 pixels short of that I
think so exactly and so yeah that can
mess up some some sprite sheet
calculation
yeah absolutely so anyways who's inching
also the thing is that simpering when
you plug HDMI in you actually you
actually get one of those rare things
where it actually gets your tells you're
apt to change the size and so your app
needs to know how to respond to that we
actually had one app earlier that had a
giant purple or green fringe on it and
that actually was because oh we just
never realized that the size change can
come in as late as it did so if you do I
said you have to watch out oh wait don't
chain it can come in any time you're
gonna come in anytime you got to be
ready for it so yeah I mean we've said
it before we'll say it again
programming Android is not like
programming a game console it's like
programming a desktop or a web browser
you have to be ready for hardware to be
different ooh
when you select hard difficulty you have
chickens who are blocking your way now -
I hadn't noticed that all right so that
was fun but what else you've been doing
this week down other than other than
other than flicking my sheep yeah okay
this is so in other games we have going
on
we actually have words work out which is
fun it's it's yet another another in a
long line of words games but it's done
very very well I would say that the the
excessive use of rounded rectangles is a
little unnecessary on Android but
there's some good words here like pleat
ouch
and yeah and you are you know it's a
time game so hmm well
so yeah we now we get to learn how good
is game so anyways so it's a fun game
where you're trying to draw things in a
sort of a boggle esque fashion there's a
lot of power-ups a lot of really
well-thought-out stuff I was a really
fun game on a tablet it works it works
great you know because it just scales to
fill the screen the only thing on a
tablet is the obviously you can see the
area with the ad is kind of awkward
looking and takes up a very small
portion of that top inner so I probably
could adjust for that especially games
like this you there's there's really not
much of an excuse for for not trying it
on an emulator yeah right some different
sizes it's a little bit of a pain
because honestly it we don't switch as
fast as we could between different sizes
and different layouts on the on the
emulator or on the dev tools but it's
well worth it
and it turns out that for games nowadays
I mean I think we used to see some
really bizarre things yeah absolutely
and and we still do on some devices but
if as we're you know for instance as
we're looking at devices that haven't
shipped yet which we sometimes do there
can be some crazy stuff well yeah but
it's interesting we you know we we
sometimes do it to ourselves and I think
one of things we're gonna cover in
future sessions or is is ways in which
we you have to be careful you know and
and so sometimes people make assumptions
about the way the memory and devices are
laid out sometimes they're actually some
bugs and avec it turns out that we're
affecting the way that one could
subclass various classes that people
were accidentally taking advantage of
yeah that's actually one thing you'll
notice is that the the original Android
source base you know was obviously not
100% perfect and there were a few things
that either were under specified or were
just done wrong that tend to get cleaned
up over time by AOSP contributors so for
and by us and by us yeah
so for instance we made for jellybean
yeah we made P thread POSIX compliant it
was supposed to return an error if it
couldn't give you the thread you you
wanted you know with the scheduling
and it used to just fall back and you
know still create a thread but it wasn't
what you asked for
yeah and we made it do the right thing
which is return an error and that broke
everybody everything because it turns
out nobody was checking why would you
check for errors on P thread because in
there yeah exactly so we had a ton of
games and other apps that would spin up
threads and then sit there waiting like
hey all right just waiting for that
thread to spin up of the thread to spend
exactly yeah Bodo boom boom and nothing
would happen so so yeah so you have to
be used to be a little bit cautious on
that sometimes reading our docs actually
is a good thing and and also just you
know adhering to standards even even
when it doesn't break you you know the
other thing that happened I believe is
the Ice Cream Sandwich time frame was we
tightened up the j'ni referencing
restrictions oh we've done that several
times because we you know and this is
usually to to make things faster well
some of the things that happen to you
but when we had single threaded you know
everywhere mm-hmm
they're kind of two things we did it
once we went we went Multi CPU and at
the same time we also tightened up J and
I and I think there they sort of what
hand-in-hand but for a long time
we weren't cleaning up j'ni very
effectively so you could you could
pretty much guarantee that if you
referenced something from the JVM that
reference would always exist in J and I
as long as it existed in the JVM well
basically what we were doing is all BPM
the Eclair the opaque hand the open
court unquote opaque handles that we're
getting passed back were just references
to two members chunks of memory and
addresses and now aging and then we
switch to actually passing opaque
handles right we're actually idols yeah
because because at some point we
realized we you know we're not gonna
make this GC any faster yeah unless we
start rearranging memory exactly so so
one of that one of the things everyone
should doing in addition to using check
J&I is to also build against the latest
versions of the NDK and build against
the latest versions of the SDK be very
very careful especially with native
tools especially if you're using any
pre-built libraries because that you
know you don't know how those pre-built
libraries were compiled maybe they were
compiled with an older version of
UK maybe they're compiled with the build
flag so in general I you know especially
with but with binary libraries be very
very cautious yeah this is um the reason
we're talking about this is because
recently it's become very obvious to sit
as we do more address layout address
space layout randomization and and just
screw with the address space in
different ways I old code that was
compiled with very old NDK is not
relocatable in the same way that the
newer code is and this also goes for
code that may have been compiled with
the different tool chains so if you're
using some other random tool chain to
generate Android code be aware that we
only test against the NDK yeah so
definitely you know all you guys are
there I know there's there's a bunch of
other I mean a lot of get a lot for a
long time Chris stacks was like doing
all sorts of cool stuff that we you know
later introduced into the NDK so you can
definitely run into problems there so
just be very very cautious that you're
always using the latest version of our
tools because we're that's going to
guarantee the the longest forward
compatibility that we can yep alright
alright so anyway it's a cool game I you
know I don't really don't have much to
say about it other than they really need
to make this dialogue dismissible with
the back key as general vac he must work
oh sorry oh do you should be you should
be Frankenstein oh you know hipster
Frankenstein hipster Frank with the
beard yeah yeah he's that guy's you keep
the teacher just so I can be I can have
I can have I have sunglasses
your palette is not cool as mine because
yours is shiny and silver and mine is
blackish colored that's purple purposely
that's it's amethyst and this one isn't
silver don't fool yourself it's
champagne it is actually that's you know
because we're the Sex and the City girls
basically yeah absolutely
yeah yeah that's why that's why I've got
this hat it's all about accessorizing
alright so let's look at a game that
actually unlike I like words workout is
somewhat entered somewhat up actually oh
my god that's small you can bring up the
tablet now mr. Pham ster
and yeah there we are this is actually a
portrait now I know look at that that is
high production values right there now
you'll notice this is one of those that
times in which actually looking at
screen size is useful because by default
this is of course on an mdpi device so
you're getting very small text very
small icons yeah which game is guys this
is maths twister emic now you knew Tet
it's not from the US because it's got
maths in it and no one it known in the
US would actually call it math - it
would definitely be a something coming
from somewhere else and you know usually
with some K in it or something like that
maybe Australia I'm not sure I didn't
look for this developers from but
clearly not from here did you know in
Australia yeah they call soccer soccer
well as you know originally that the
term soccer came from the UK we're not
that is we just and we just kept using
it and they said stop we're calling it
football I love this because it's it's
like we can make a 600-mile journey
across England in just a few seconds
that's right it all depends on what I
happened to be talking over the hold on
hold on wait I've got a got one more uh
now I've got a nurse or a dad come on
give me a Liverpudlian come on p-bog
Kinlan no no that's nothing like it
that's that's the dude that tried to
sound like Ringo in Yellow Submarine
that is so absolutely true well you know
the thing about a Beatles - is they
actually were coached to sound like that
because they they came on about like no
Americans gonna understand you you know
really like like what's-his-name in that
one movie yes exactly so so they said no
we're gonna they were there they taught
them so they actually said you've got to
slow down the way you speak like all
right well we'll speak like this then
and there you know sound like we're
always on something they give me Brad
Pitt from snatch yeah yes exactly
exactly
what you didn't know that because that's
what I was talking about Dan got it all
right that's enough enough about certs
get on to math twister so here I'll go
with a bit
for a fine accent for this math twister
is is a highly educational game we can
choose untimed and different levels of
difficulty which will throw math
problems at us you know what is 10% of
80 or 2 times 7 or 6 times 9 or 10% of 7
day and they get kind of fun there now
George Harrison's Butler that's right
something like that yeah so by the way I
just want to I just want to pause for a
second to recognize our new producer
producer Louie Louie is not miked no
sorry he's I'm sorry this island so
pretty so producer lewis's name is Louis
but he spells it Louie which really bugs
me because my last name is louis and i
spell a louis he's not on camera today
because his phenomenal handsomeness
would would cause all of us to look
hideous in comparison i say yes like
like couldn't King Louie are you saying
yes today I'm not Scottish all right
let's go anyways that's kind of cool it
sort of combines a falling tower action
with with math you know definitely in
terms of tablet.this there's a little
bit of work to be done you know that's
and I was actually a little surprised to
see that this game was a landscape game
that actually starts off in portrait and
goes to landscape in general if you're
gonna walk to one dimension you should
kind of walk to one dimension you know
whether if you're gonna have a title
screen that's in landscape and your game
should be in landscape yeah you never
want to make the user actually have to
rotate well unless you're just trying to
get obese children to exercise what yeah
I know I wish somebody had done that for
me when I was young so um maybe that's
why they call it maths twister hadn't
occurred because you have to twist the
tablet I had just assumed that it was
the you know what Mormons do for
flirting it's funny because I actually I
was visiting some friends and you know
they went to school at Brigham Young
University with and yeah they brought
out this video and darned if it wasn't
the sexiest game of Twister you've ever
seen oh yeah I said that well that the
entwisted I was as beyond flirting there
that's treacherous which is sort of into
heavy heavy petting already when you get
back exactly right yeah totally uh crazy
yes drunken not drunken completely sober
party twister at BYU all right all right
all those things things I never knew
about that's math twister you definitely
I think that the biggest issues that I
have heard our tablet optimization in
terms of that I think true the game is
fine on a phone we played all on a
tablet why because this has cool HDMI
and and it's running jelly bean maja
thank you alright so one more game which
is also portrait it is jungle jumper and
no there's nothing sexual about this
case just in case you're curious there's
no theme here weren't initially thinking
about that but now I can't unhear it I'm
sorry I'm sorry to all our viewers out
there so the thing I love about jungle
jumper is this like Stuart Little
title screen they've got it's like it's
seriously get out of that but you know
what it's not stir a little I don't know
it says this I don't know if you've ever
heard of this but Able's island oh okay
do you know what I'm talking about it
was like a Newbery Award winner you can
actually jump off the side I've never
done that before we didn't realize you
could die jump you know yeah seriously
did you did you read Abel's on no I
didn't actually
well in that case we can't share a
moment I like the fact it was just just
believe me the Abel's Island guy looked
exactly like the jungle jumper guy okay
well I do like the fact that that you
actually get nicely and soundly eaten by
these guys when you jump on them yeah
they've got some good animations I mean
obviously it wasn't made for a tablet in
the sense that the the background
graphics are a little fuzzy at this
resolution that's always a little bit
disappointing especially when you can
see they're you know they're they're
pretty much vector graphics so the you
know probably could have been
you scaled not too much expense but yeah
I mean this game is designed to be small
I would love to see it have a little
more animation and it does you know it's
like to me well and to tell the truth I
mean this is sort of like air attack HD
where yeah it's it's actually not as fun
on a tablet because it's meant to to
have a smaller place - I do love their
attack HD on a tablet that I like it
well on a phone though it's so much
easier it is easy ah I ran into his but
there we are
really I was I was no he died didn't eat
it he didn't eat me I was just but
killed so that's disturbing I know so
let's see what else is coming up well
next week
I think either next week or the week
after should see the ceremonial
untagging of our Android fifth
anniversary ale very exciting exactly
the whole team has been looking forward
to this I'd say what is it you know yeah
it's alright blend it to Malta three
hops I can't remember off the top of my
head what they are but I hear it was the
inaugural outing of our new brewery and
I understand it ended up a little
hoppier no it's you wanted yeah
interesting little accident with the
hops but so that's alright we made more
like yay that is a California thing guys
it says very fitting yeah Bob's hops
yeah pretty much
because barley makes you fat you know
that wasn't an accident I actually did
that by design behind the scenes oh
really I biked it without with extra ha
so Daniel Pham hamster yeah ruined the
fifth anniversary
your words ruined yes not my weeks he
made our fifth anniversary into a bitter
drink to swallow do you do that with
thicker with our code to just like I can
neither confirm nor deny that Daniel
Pham ninja checking master I do I had
every now and then you just find a rogue
feature and yeah it's like how did that
get that ninjas
yeah Wi-Fi direct that was a total ninja
feature yeah yeah it really was
yeah mediacodec dot encode oh yeah
totally - future all right so so yes
continue to get on the moderator we
actually do look at your suggestions and
the best of these games we do present
over to our buddies over the Google Play
team and say please take a look at them
they may or may not feature them and not
only that but we actually we are working
on some collections of our very own yes
we're very excited about that I we've
seen that collections actually are fun
people who like them I was really
excited to see the retro gaming
collection which again we talked a lot
about retro game titles here and we said
we really wanted to see it's a really
cool we really wanted to do a collection
because we're like well you can't put a
retro game on the front page of Google
Play because a lot of people aren't
gonna understand it yeah it's gonna blow
their mind you know right we're not part
of their system yeah exactly you know
like 8-bit audio and graphics but people
who want it it raised them like elected
up yeah I'm like oh yes I'm seeing my
childhood right here yeah yeah back when
I didn't read Abel's Odyssey that's okay
because you had a childhood with 8-bit
graphics I used to dream of 8-bit
graphics oh yeah I remember when I was a
child I used to live in a shoebox with a
lid yeah well yours had a lid ah lucky
man yeah all right well punchy yeah
indeed we talked about our games talked
about some game development we are going
to be shifting this this show right time
and time wise maybe I don't know it
might be watch big changes coming up we
will announce it on Google+
yes but basically we just have to get
through this month and then we take some
water drink some water we get through
this month and we are going to change
things up so keep an eye on us and keep
the comments coming now let's see what
people are saying on the comment stream
yeah we actually we actually have
typical typical YouTube comments really
are there people being like okay so
here's a question about the transformer
prime is the transformer the best
Android tablet or do you guys just use
it see well the transformer prime has
some some advantages it is not
definitely not a bad Android tablet I
don't know if I'd go so far as to say
it's the best fourth as far as things
that are shipping now that we can get
our hands on and reliable reliably get
several backup units it is the very best
at providing HDMI out it's got really
good HDMI out options Asus added some
things to the base Android system that
allow it to do things like rotate into
portrait mode so that makes our show a
lot easier yeah that's I think that's
the primary reason we're using on the
show we have them and they have this
really cool feature you know we don't
have HDMI on our own tablets had to say
you know the on the Nexus 7 so if we had
an X except Nexus tablet HDMI out we
might use it I mean if you think about
it the Nexus 7 in a lot of ways is a
stripped down transformer price it's you
know it's got the essentially the same
processing power but a smaller screen no
rear camera you know just a yeah and all
the options are taken off yeah so
fortunately we have a lot of experience
with that chipset and that piece of
hardware so it's a lot easier to show
now there are some disadvantages to the
transformer prime it's out of all of the
it's sort of the odd man out on
rendering unlike almost all mobile chips
it's not a tiled renderer it's a forward
ruler and that means that it's very very
sensitive to performance characteristics
that that the tiler can handle very
easily and vice versa yeah so like you
know for example you know there's
there's there's there's three different
renderers essentially on Android there
we have a tile based deferred tile based
and we have immediate mode or
this and this tablet is if this chip
said it's really cool if you need to do
some really clever effects that involve
reading stuff back out of the buffer
because the buffer is updated in the you
know the in this tasty the screen
rappers updated in real time so it's
actually really fast to go and read
stuff out with a tile-based renderer or
a deferred renderer it means that it has
to reconstruct that piece of the buffer
when you want it in the middle of
rendering and that can slow you down an
immense amount so there are certain
kinds of full-screen effects that this
kind of chips that can do that are very
difficult to do on a tile-based renderer
yeah it's you know when you think about
the way the hardware's put together it's
not so much that the tile-based renderer
is bad at it is that it's significantly
better at not doing that yeah so in
other words you're not you're not
actually doing something that yeah that
the hardware is bad at it's just that it
has to forego a whole set of
optimization right and the problem is
this you know this hardware is designed
to work the other way and so what this
so the tile-based renderers tend to
actually have performance problems when
you start having to force them into sort
of direct mode rendering because they
just really designed to work that way
now on the other hand tile-based renders
excel at some things you know for
instance if you're doing read backs from
the frame buffer for blending they're
they can be very very fast absolutely
many tile-based renderers especially the
ones that are fully deferred and have
geometry sorting are incredible at
dealing with completely unsorted
geometry which is a real benefit because
sorting geometry is a not actually a
tractable problem you can get close but
it's sort of a traveling salesman thing
and some moving eye but also it takes up
a lot of CPU resources so yeah now that
being said a lot of the drivers for
tile-based renderers also do some of
that sorting and venting on the cpu
driver so there is the res additional
cpu load already in a tile-based
renderer just kind of to begin with well
and it's it's always a corporation
between the CPU and then the magic sauce
really is and you know the big the big
trade secret is how much is done where
is you know it's kind of right and
exactly you know how very true it's like
the you know but but but basically but
yes so in theory also in a theory is
that and this isn't really proven maybe
that
immediate mode guys would say when you
get into really really huge amounts of
geometry when you start doing things
like having procedural geometry
basically that you start running into
things that immediate Miller renderers
do better than tile-based renderers and
I think the jury is still out we'll have
to wait to see what happens with well
nobody's gonna do that we don't know
nobody I'd be really surprised
OpenGL 3 is starting to add these kinds
of features in so I think you know I
think we'll have to look you know five
years down the line we're gonna
definitely have api's and chips that'll
support you know doing that kind of job
well but but the thing is it's not it's
not so much that this your amount of
geometry its if I mean the same reason
that that sorting is a different problem
no you're right you know on a tiler
you're you're really dealing with just a
very large number of frustra basically
so you've you've already pre clipped a
lot of your trials so the chances of
getting interpenetration is very low now
at the point where we are sitting yeah
as application developers when we say
sort your geometry we're not actually
thinking about sort of your trial we're
usually thinking about sorting it on the
object level right because will will
draw entire videos at a time exactly so
that's actually that's a difficult
problem because you get these
interpreted trading things absolutely
that's and that's actually a big
challenge it's a challenge anyways
because you also have certain geometry
that is translucent and so you actually
have to maintain to that in proper you
know front to back order right while you
actually want to maintain all of your
geometry that it isn't translucent and
back to front order and so you have to
you have to watch out for all those
inter dependencies as well so it's not
like it's you know I mean this isn't a
secret to anybody because desktop cards
have been doing this for a long long
time it's really only in the mobile
space that tyler's are super popular
absolutely but a lot of it's because as
you're saying you know with deferred
renderers or I'm sorry with with media
mode remember renderers you get more
predictable performance it's easier to
reason about what the GPU is doing yeah
it's easier to do multi pass effects but
and and it's easier to take advantage of
these you know super long shaders that
you've got
but it does mean that it went when
you're a much more resource constrained
environment
yeah it's no shine they don't try
exactly and so I think that um so it is
interesting so want to think one of
things that's nice about this is one to
see that most the games aren't really
well on it I mean honestly you know the
vast majority of games on Android do
great on the transformer prime and it's
really exciting also for us the other
thing that's nice about transformer
prime is they did get jellybean and it's
really really nice like the difference
is smoothness when this guy going to
jellybean was huge because it felt fast
to begin with but yeah I never had a
real problem with it but yeah when you
see jelly it's the same way like my
Galaxy Nexus when I upgraded to
jellybean I'm like wow I feel like I
just got a new phone yeah and it's
because that you know we did a lot of
work which we're actually really hoping
to bring to you over the next few months
talk about how you can dj''q your
applications the same way we need to
make the operating system mostly cuz all
the guys that did the DJ King sit like
two cubes away from us and when are you
gonna do this on they actually hate us
and they're like would you go away but
yeah yeah yeah and when we say we bugged
them we mean actually microphones in
their office so we need all their
secrets the important thing that we
added this tool called systrace and
systrace is really really awesome server
i'll show you an example so on one GPU
we could actually look at systrace and
say alright the GPU is rendering here
and then the thread went to sleep for
this period of time and then the GP was
rendering here why did the thread go to
sleep well this ride went to sleep
because that point we didn't read back
from the GPU and we could say and that
was the intent entire chunk of time
which we could actually measure and you
can see that and systrace was actually
the GPU going hey well I'm gonna do a
bunch of calculation now this sucks so
well now remember of course that there's
two components to any read-back right
there's the there's the fact that you're
you know you have to install out the the
GPU writing inside but you also have to
make sure that the resource isn't in use
on either side right yeah so it's not
just sorry so you need to collect the
tiles yes do all of you know collapse
your deferred render yes and you also
need to do a synchronization between the
CPU and GPU and that's what really kills
you
and one one thing that we've noticed
with video is that no matter how fast
you are coherent CPUs and GPUs are kind
of kick-ass no you know because because
here's the problem yeah it's not
actually it's not actually a
synchronization problem it's it's more a
sequencing problem I know I was kidding
that is but anyway the the problem is or
the solution I should say is that you
just never want to have the GPU and CPU
holding on to the same resource once and
and so and you know if you're working on
a desktop part you you already know how
this works because you have to deal with
PCI synchronization and the solution is
staging buffers so you don't do a read
back into a texture and then immediately
use it you do a read back this frame
while you're reading the read back that
you did three frames ago yeah and it
actually it's actually one of the things
people do actually for reflection is
that you actually don't calculate a
reflection every frame but you're using
every other frame you know maybe every
two frames you know depending on how
much you're allowed okay all right well
now let's calculate a reflection now
we'll apply that and that's for two
frames ago but that's okay because
actually the user can't really tell
that's on top of some other wavy mushy
thing right right and yeah and a lot of
it depends of course on on who's doing
the read bag the problem is that the the
GPU is considered to be a user of that
texture from the point that a draw call
involving it is submitted to the point
where it retires yeah so that's actually
a huge length of time that the GPU is
not in fact using the texture absolutely
and in fact most of these GPUs are are
executing completely serially so for
instance it's it's no problem for the
GPU to read back a texture as long as
it's not actually writing to it right
now but having the CPU read it back or
if you need to do any kind of processing
that involves the CPU which as you noted
before you don't really know because a
lot of this the magic happens there is
right driver each each one of these
chips is not just a self-contained
magical graphics now value
yeah it's it's part of an ecosystem of
software that lives in multiple places
and yeah so it's interesting and
sometimes you actually for some of these
effects you actually can do them
entirely on the CPU
you know like thing and some of their
guys some of the guys you just fake it
out you're like all right I know I've
got approximate this geometry let's
calculate it on the CPU let's not even
get the GPU involved and sometimes like
you that's your best choice right
because especially if you've if you've
got things where you've got a lot of
recursion and your other version yeah at
work looks like yeah yeah yeah
feedback great feedback yeah so so let's
say you're doing an IIR filter which
which depends on feeding back the
results of previous calculations well
nuts that's incredibly difficult for a
GPU to do well because unless you're
doing doing entire frame buffers at a
time right so but CPUs for well you know
and that's one of they goes great on
these on these newer devices we have
some very very powerful GPUs with you
know vector processing built into them
you know neons can do a lot of really
cool stuff so it definitely is an
opportunity to actually go and balance
some of the load between the CPU and GPU
and and especially when you get into
these tyler's you can really you can
start to guess at what they're gonna do
badly and you'll usually be right all
right
I think and then that's it the world's
world record for longest answer to
complete yeah question yeah is there
anything else on this stream that's an
interesting at all well I guess at some
point way way in the distant future the
thing is we keep pushing kind of two
things one is the is the expectations
for quality so you know well you know
we're we're pushing more geometry or
pushing more textures or pushing more
layering and so we're keeping up with
the hardware the second thing is we're
going a higher resolution you know I
mean and every time we go higher
resolution it's kind of funny we sort of
take a step forward and a step back step
forward in the step yeah exactly
well and so I have my own personal
answer for you and of course the answer
is yes
see JavaScript right yeah because I mean
that's why we have the
is because this incredibly inefficient
mode of programming that that grew out
of a markup language and and an
experiment in computer science yeah as
now become capable of running almost
anything as long as you're on a
massively multi-core computer with
gigabytes of RAM exactly but on moat and
and so I think that that trend will
probably continue especially now that
we've really gotten for multi-core into
the desktops but here's the problem
for a certain class of games I think
well won't have to optimize here's a
problem for mobile the little thing I
like to call the laws of physics there's
certain amount of weight you're willing
to carry in your pocket it cannot change
the laws of physics that's right thank
you I was waiting for that I know you
were the weight does that make you evil
Scotty knows it does Yeah right all
right never mind I don't know what I was
doing anyway the point is so you have a
specific amount of battery yeah you have
a specific size and a specific tolerant
for heat now if you've ever felt in the
back of let's say a giant you know Mac
Pro or one of these big windows
workstations or anything like that you
know that the type of computational
power that it takes to run let's say it
totally ills my house it's awesome like
I don't need to need to turn on the
heater at certain times I just turn up
them yeah all I do is check my gmail
yeah that's what I call it VA right yeah
exactly
so I you know and none of that's to take
away from the miracle that is modern
computing but to get that into the size
I mean is he thin that cracks well he
was doing right yeah it's the same way
that you can be like well gee you know
transatlantic ocean liners can produce
huge amounts of horsepower so I guess we
don't have to worry about designing cars
to be aerodynamic well no because you're
never going to get that you know that
engine into that size and make it work
efficiently I think I think on mobile
it's always good it's always good when
you can design
efficiently you can always help the
users battery life you know we you know
sometimes the reason why people stop
playing mobile games like this game is
sucking away all of my battery and you
know you're being more efficient is
always better you know that being said
you know what we are getting to a point
in which certain kinds of optimizations
aren't as important yes and for a lot of
games I mean there's research there's a
lot of there's a whole series of games
it just doesn't have to care about
certain things but memory is always an
important resource we have a lot of
devices that have you know different
sciences of vm's different sizes of
actual physical memory different amounts
of stuff that's running on top of them
so it's always good to be resource
sensitive on you know all these resource
constrains but there are trade-offs you
know I mean yeah sometimes you can you
can trade memory for greater CPU
absolutely that's less the case in it
than it used to be and CPUs have really
gotten fast in memory buses have like I
mean we you know we could we could make
cars more efficient today we could build
them out of titanium but the problem is
they really really really expensive and
no one would buy them
so you December you I think don't you
have a titanium car no don't but that
sounds like a brilliant circuit exactly
yeah I know people do that it's a beard
that's so any case you know so so I mean
there's a point in which obviously
you're what I'm saying is that in terms
of efficiency there's a point in what
you want to say you have to stop and say
look it's just not worth it we've hit
the 90-95 percentile of what you know
what we're going to get but I think that
that you know especially in mobile it's
it's it's force us to relook at
efficiency and say you know this is
really important stuff which is fun
because we love it but we're computer
scientists oh yeah and we love actually
looking at those kinds of problems
remember though that actually speed is
not as important as it once was but
smoothness is so a lot of times we're
doing things that don't actually
increase the speed of the application
what they do is increase the
responsiveness and make certain that the
animations can play at 60 frames per
second so making something twice as fast
isn't hard making it consistently 60 FPS
when you start it out at 15 FPS or 30
FPS is often extremely difficult because
especially if you're trying to make it
consistent consistent yeah and and if
you're trying to you know one of the one
of the real challenges on Android is
you're trying to use a very small amount
of memory
targeting a very high-resolution screen
and and you are fighting the fact that
you thought you also have garbage
collection going on that's every once in
a while that's gonna take 20 30
milliseconds I love how a very small
amount of memory yeah I know and is yeah
like 64 megabytes of memory you know is
well you know right or you know I mean
if we have a gig or two gigs and in a
new device I mean that's like I used to
dream of that well exactly I mean I
actually I actually remember that 16
megabytes of memory for Michigan for a
computer was just something beyond like
that was what professional photo
workstations had and that was like five
thousand dollars were their memories
it's the fact that we have that for a
process so you know it's always good to
take these things into consideration but
that's when I when I talk about quality
you know the quality keeps going up we
keep finding ways of using this
computing resource so I think that we're
not gonna be at a time anytime soon
maybe 20 30 years out we're gonna be
saying yeah you know we don't need to
worry about this but I think that for we
still have a pretty long cycle before
that stuff becomes unimportant yep all
right I think I think is there anything
else on the stream that's just really uh
knocking you out no no all right all
right well thank you for joining us as
always vote stuff up in the moderator
page let us know what you're playing let
us know what you want us to talk about
we're gonna try to you know mix up the
format of the show a little we've got
some exciting stuff coming on as soon as
we get some sleep so thank you once
again for joining us and our friends
over at logging - yes I was actually
Daniel Pham for providing this delicious
IPA that we're drinking now all right
god bless us everyone
little Android play us out go bless us
everyone there we are